I worked at a video store I would get a
list every day of what you know they
call these people your your videos are
due
did they ever yell at you or get mad
sometimes yes oh yeah did they come in a
few minutes later and just shove the
videos
aggressively and then walk out I'd love
to hear that with you yeah I'd love to
hear that phone call you made like
you're the enforcer for the video store
like it'll be like um uh hello who's
this
sir I don't know what the [__] you're
saying you better get a hurry up by here
right now okay
what you like you you owe us videos or
whatever or whatever
or whatever
yeah well it was the worst part of the
job but you had a list of where those
videos were and you tracked those
[__] down right I mean the worst was
that when it was like a girl's gone wild
or something
like uh you're coming you know hey you
pervert bring your video back yeah
let me ask you something uh JD can you
reenact like let's take yourself back to
the video store and I've uh I'm like two
weeks later my a Girl's Gone Wild video
like call me up
hello
yes uh Mr uh Stern uh I this is the uh
JD from the movie gallery or Jamie from
the movie gallery I have seen uh you
have some videos out later but you know
your own name sir are you JD or Jamie
I'm Jamie I'm Jamie uh it's a video is
out late and uh you know you might have
to return him I can't remember how
exactly it went but it was it was very
uncomfortable yeah you sound like a real
[__] I think I can beat your ass the
girl's gone wild for two weeks yeah I'm
keeping my girls gone wild but by the
way that girl's got wild tape isn't in
too good of shape anyway I think you
should let me keep it
foreign